hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
a twelfth of August today and you're
watching games but news let's talk about
some things Sony have announced that the
ps4 system update 2 point 0 is coming
and it's bringing a bunch of new
features for the hardware a while back
sony were regaling us for the feature
that would allow a friend to take
control of your game if you were having
trouble with something now that seems to
be coming in the form of share play or
what Sony is calling a virtual couch
allowing for an online local co-op
experience it will let you either
virtually hand off your controller to a
friend or invite a friend to your local
multiplayer game and this won't require
your friend to own the game in question
alongside that Sony have included the
ability to search for PlayStation users
by their real name a way to upload saved
videos straight to YouTube a dedicated
YouTube app and there will be real-time
activity feeds in the what's new section
the update is set to land sometime this
fall in other playstation 4 news Sony
have sold 10 million of the buggers now
revealing the figure at Gamescom the
very big number of first a console sold
through to consumers and not just those
shipped it accounts for worldwide sales
as of august 10 and according to sony it
represents the fastest and strongest
growth in PlayStation hardware in Sony's
history as far as software is concerned
sony has sold a combined 30 million
copies of retail and downloaded ps4
games through the PlayStation Store as
of august 10 and resting Lee it was
apparently x.x looks exactly in 2008 who
said history has shown us that the first
company to reach 10 million in console
sales when is the generation battle of
course at the time he was referring to
the xbox 360 hitting the milestone
before the ps3 that was amazing it news
is surprising an awful lot of people the
hotly-anticipated rise of the Tomb
Raider is apparently going to be x boxed
exclusive during the Microsoft gamescom
press conference the reveal stated that
the game was coming during the holiday
period of 2015 exclusively to xbox
platforms it's too early to say whether
this is just a timed exclusive and the
game will eventually come to pc and
playstation or not but you guys are less
than pleased at the moment well except
those of you who have xboxes the
official tomb raider tumblr posted a
letter explaining the exclusivity which
detailed the Crystal Dynamics believes
this is the best thing for the tomb
raider sequel they're creating head of
the studio Darrell Gallagher explains we
know Microsoft will get behind this game
more than any support we've had from
them in the past we believe this will be
a step to really forging the tomb raider
brand as one of the biggest in gaming
the studio have said that they haven't
forgotten their fans on playstation or
pc though saying that lara croft and the
temple of osiris is coming to those
platforms in december and tomb raider
the definitive edition is available on
ps4 do you guys reckon the sequel to
tomb raider will stay xbox exclusive or
not and are you bothered or pleased by
the news let me know that is it for me
today you can check out all our games
com coverage on site and i will see you
same time tomorrow